I want to bring up this document which
you've entered into evidence Jesse Dei
in curriculum model principles and
practices this was put out by the
California community colleges and really
lays out Point by Point what it is they
expect to see in the classroom could you
before we dive into the documents
details could you tell us what is the
import of this
well this is one of several documents
that
the State Community College system uh
issued to inform the individual
districts and colleges
um how to apply the new Dei rules and
this document in particular is this is
what we want to see when you are
applying Dei in the classroom this is
how you incorporate it into your
curriculum this is these are the kind of
practices you should use on not use or
the types of language you should use and
not use uh to be compliant with the
state's definition of Dei
so this will be a sort of reference for
you know if this system is implemented
where professors are evaluated uh where
this is incorporated into their
evaluations be like this is the
reference document are you aligning with
what is laid out here it's one of
several sources that that they're going
to be referencing that's correct
yes
and looking inside of it this is the
kind of big picture Vision they lay out
that one you develop and Implement a
pedagogy or curriculum that promotes a
race conscious and intersectional lens
and equip students to engage with the
world as Scholars and citizens develops
and implements a pedagogy that Fosters
an anti-racive or anti-racist and
inclusive environment for minoritized
students
demonstrates an ability to teach
culturally affirming pedagogy
what is your reaction to that bill as
someone who would be affected by these
new standards
well again it's it's uh it's this this
relative terminology is kind of the way
I look at it anti-racism anti-racist
um intersectionality
um
yeah yeah you you ask five different
people and they're gonna have five
different definitions
and I don't know how
um to work in the anti-racist ideology
to Boyle's Law
I'm sorry that Boyle was a white
scientist you know physicist 200 plus
years ago or something along those lines
but
um it it really becomes I think it's
Preposterous because
the periodic table of the elements is
what I'm charged with teaching students
about explaining how that was
constructed etc etc and how it works and
um
I think it's relative in the way they're
going to
evaluate me and it's not objective
and
um I have real concerns about my future
in Academia as do you know the other
people who have enjoined in the lawsuit
as well
um because
administrators
you know sometimes
you know I I would say I'm trying to
figure out the most polite way to say
this they they can bear grudges and so
um
I think that that evaluation language
can be interpreted so many different
ways well you're not going far enough
yeah I recognize that you did X Y and Z
but you didn't go far enough you could
have went further
so that's that's kind of how this I
think and I'm anticipating this working
I just want to add that there's a
certain hilarity like you know say we
like put on our little Marxist hats for
a second here there's a certain hilarity
to the fact that it's administrators who
are frequently paid you know a pretty
penny uh in the college environment as
well as some of the Dei Consultants
where now there's like a pretty thriving
industry a lot of these CI consulting
firms make Bank
um and there's a little bit of
absurdity to these very highly paid
professionals being the sort of
enforcers of this
um you know and implementing a very
top-down thing which I would imagine
many students at California community
colleges do not come from the most you
know economically privileged backgrounds
in the entire world and or are working
really hard to put themselves through
school and to attempt to you know work
their way up in the world and so I just
think that there's also something kind
of fascinating about that of like who
are the people doing the enforcement of
this
um if they actually care about you know
lifting the people who are the absolute
most oppressed there's a certain uh
absurdity to the fact that many of them
I think are probably paid an awful lot
of money very handsomely to do this type
of thing
um
so I want to add to that there's a
there's a bit of a tempest happening in
the uh
um
not the community college system but the
state college system so in California
you have the UCS University of
California you have the Cal State and
then you have the community college
system so in the Cal State right now
they are negotiating
and I think it's system-wide with
faculty unions and administration is
playing Hardball they they want to give
minimal raise but contrast that to
administrators whose raises have far
outpaced
faculty and inflation so to speak and
you have you have administrators in the
California State University system so
that would be you know places like Cal
State LA
Cal State Fresno Cal State Fullerton Etc
you have administrators that are making
you know just under a million dollars
you know college presidents and then you
you it just kind of goes down from there
they get they get housing allowances
there are people within the Cal State
system who get a housing allowance and
mileage which is greater than what
professors monthly pay is
and so I think you point out something
that's really good that these
administrators who were this is where
this is all coming from
um and you have faculty you know that
are definitely Marxist
um as well but you have these the
administrators who are who are really
pushing this
making tremendous amounts of money far
more than they would ever make in the
private sector
and I think you point out something that
just is really remarkable it's it's
hypocrisy it's our you know
um there's a lot of different adjectives
we could probably come up with to
describe this but
um
yeah it's it's exactly that you have
administrators making huge amounts of
money compared to faculty and they're
the ones decrying
you know white privilege and everything
else I I know one aspect of the lawsuit
too is about vagueness because if I were
in this position reading some of this
would be really confusing I wouldn't
even quite understand what the
actionable like instruction is because
of the way that the language is just the
the the kind of Flowery or you know
abstract language they did helpfully
provide a glossary which I've pulled up
here and uh one of the terms that I know
uh lit caught Liz's interest is uh
watering up uh could you uh share with
us Liz what watering up is and I mean
this is the problem with so much of this
like I just literally don't know what
this means I am a journalist I spend all
day writing words and parsing their
meaning and this is not super clear to
me
um I mean read a little bit of it our
listening audience watering up is
apparently you know instructional
practices with the science of learning
that we can Apprentice students to be
active agents in their own learning
instead of watering them down with
compliance oriented deficit views this
process requires students to build and
braid together multiple neural
relational and experiential processes to
produce their own unique learning
acceleration process I'm sorry this
feels like if you fed chat GPT HR
buzzwords it's not clear to me how a
professor is actually supposed to
implement this or how this is a useful I
mean the thing that I just keep coming
back to you because ever since becoming
a mom I've been pretty interested in a
lot of the stuff related to phonics
education and the crisis related to how
children have been taught how to read in
many public schools in this country
which is obviously at a different level
than the level that we're talking about
but I just keep coming back to this
question of like wait a second at many
schools across the country there's this
huge problem which is that like there
isn't enough instructional time or
suitable enough instruction in the first
place to get kids to the level that they
need to be at and then you also look at
College classroom environments and it's
not clear to me why we ought to be
trying to get instructors to be spending
more time on these very vague
wishy-washy Concepts versus actually
ensuring that kids and young adults
learn the things that they need to be
learning they need to learn how to read
or like what you're talking about
um you know they they need to be
figuring out how to uh you know the
basics of dosage like one of the things
that I just keep coming back to is
when we Orient ourselves more toward
these things
are we setting people up to fail because
we're actually I mean it comes at a cost
and what's the cost actually useful
instructional time
do you have talk on that bill
that's exactly right it takes away we
have a limited amount of time
and we have a tremendous amount of
material that we have to go over and
skills that they have to learn
and
I think what you said too at the
beginning was right that it is
there's multiple definitions of these
words this administrator or this
Advocate or
um
I want to say you know I think Advocate
maybe where grifter maybe a good word
um
they have a definition of this word and
somebody else has a different definition
of the word well how am I going to be
objectively evaluated in my faculty
evaluation if I've got these multiple
definitions of the word that I'm looking
at whose do I go with
yeah I and also to be it strikes me as a
little insulting to people's time I
recall I came from a more privileged
background but I still you know was
working as I made my way through college
and my time was really scarce and if I
had been forced to in my view waste more
time on these types of things versus
actually getting useful instruction that
would have been really frustrating to me
I would imagine most community college
students in the California system feel
much the same way and in a sense this is
very disrespectful to people who might
be working a few jobs to pay their way
through college
um to then force them to spend time on
things that are perhaps pretty unrelated
to them actually securing the type of
success that they they hope to get later
on Zach could you also take us to the
um collectivism individualism
definitions
this is the one that uh yeah this is the
one that jumped out to me uh their
definitions from the glossary of
collectivism was an individual sense of
connection to and responsibility for
members of their group community so
sounds sounds very warm and fuzzy
individualism the valuing of the
individual over the value of groups or
society as a whole so I mean this is an
incredibly buy these are both incredibly
biased definitions clearly written by
someone more sympathetic to collectivism
and and look you you can be a
collectivist I think history would show
it's the wrong way to think about human
nature but using the state to impose
that kind of Orthodoxy on academics
people who are supposed to be
intellectuals are are free thinkers is
incredibly disturbing to me and you know
fire as the foundation for individual
rights and expressions I've got to
assume there's some people that are made
uncomfortable by this as well Jesse like
what is just your reaction as someone
who is trying to stand up for individual
rights so that seeing that sort of thing
being imposed
well
I I would say as a defender of
individual rights that also includes uh
defending the individual rights of
people who want to uh
it promote collectivism
as well as individualism so I I think we
would object to
compelling anyone to embrace any
particular point of view uh whether that
be individualism or collectivism and in
both cases we would defend the person
who's
individual rights were being
um
violated but yes as an organization we
exist to specifically to defend the
rights of individuals
I think this is uh the really delightful
thing that fire does I just appreciate I
mean I think we'll talk about it in a
little bit in a few minutes here but we
really are so
um
kind of delighted by the fact that like
we can criticize so much of this and the
um you know the compelled speech here
and fire is doing such a good job of
representing these California professors
but then you also look at some of the
things happening in Florida related to
the the stopwoke act and um the sort of
Chris Ruffo uh one-man mission to create
a different sort of viewpoint Conformity
um at many schools in that state and I
really appreciate and I think we as as
Libertarians at reason also kind of
straddle that very very tight we we walk
that tightrope of like no don't mandate
that thing over there but then also even
the thing that I like you shouldn't be
mandating
um any sort of viewpoint conformity in
that realm either it's really really
important that individuals have full
ability to legitimately go out into the
world and decide what they believe and
authentically hold and articulate those
beliefs for themselves as opposed to
having any institution impose things top
down and I mean without this we don't
have through academic freedom we don't
have the ability for people to really
engage in robust discussion and come to
you know take their half truths and and
you know have them blossom in like a
very JS Mill type way thank you so much
for watching our conversation with Jesse
Appleby of fire and Professor Bill
blanken to watch another clip go here to
watch the full conversation go here